ships have been carrying people to
safety from Sudan this one is taking
them to its Shores
swathes of Sydney's people took the
first travel option back to their
country to be with their loved ones
death will find you anywhere he says
it's important we're with our families
I have been one of the loser of this war
Ashraf is a Saudi Arabia resident but
lost his mother and sister in the early
days of the war they died in a car
accident as they fled the violence you
need to go there to support my sister my
brother because because of this
they are really in bad situation Mona
was making a pilgrimage to Makkah when
Hell broke loose back home
um suffering a lot till I find a ticket
yeah because I left my child one year
and a half
you know
people flood the deck anxiously waiting
to disembark
we were offered amnesty but insist on
reaching Sudan no matter what he says
[Music]
but they're yet to see what Sudan has
become
Port Sudan has transformed into an
epicenter of displacement
hundreds are here praying they'll win
the lottery and their names will be
called
the weight already feels too long this
is madness the numbers are overwhelming
people here from all over the world
wanting to get out of Sudan as soon as
possible but struggling to find a
sustainable way to do so there have been
many promises that haven't been
fulfilled there have been many ships
that have come and gone
we are suffering she says even in Syria
we didn't see War like this
your Sudanese your husband's from Yemen
where are you going to go
actually I'm going to foreign you're
going to go to Yemen yeah you prefer
Yemen to Sudan right now yeah yeah why
you see now there is no safety
masses of people who would choose
anything else than the horror from which
they've come
Sky News Sudan